I've seen the same as you on the
internet there's a lot of scaremongering
three quarters of landlords who left
letting agents did so to sell their
products it's a short term crisis be
careful because the interest rate's
going to 17 they know that everyone's
scared average rent in this country has
gone up to 950 per month that gives the
game away a little bit vitalize is it
dead
Andrew the mortgage broker nice to see
you again nice to see you again we speak
very regularly yes I am getting a lot of
people on my social media channels
saying oh my gosh buy to this dead
Samuel the stuff that you've been
teaching for the last few years doesn't
apply anymore no interest rates are
going through the roof and I wanted to
address it with a professional right yes
and not that I'm not a professional but
you're a different level of professional
because your FCA regulators and you are
a mortgage advisor yes right
um well we get the business of uh
sorting out the finance yeah and so that
that's when this crops up I've seen the
same as you on the internet there's a
lot of um people saying that vitales is
dead because they've been listening to
the media yes and of course there's a
lot of scare mongering in fact I had
somebody last week who said uh her mum
said that be careful because she
remembers the interest rates going to 17
percent
um so buy to let is it dead no I don't
think it is if you think about a buy to
let investment it's not for two or three
years it's for 20 or 30 years and so
there will be Peaks and troughs with
rents and with with interest payments
this is a temporary
um Inc increase in interest rates
interest rates won't be sustained at
this level for the for the remainder of
the the next 20 or 30 years they will
fluctuate now at the moment
um
we're suggesting to people
don't panic and necessarily sell the
property
um or all the properties that you've got
um hold on and fight we can help them
and make recommendations as to how they
can find a way around sorting out the
problem there are various things that we
can do and recommend to them but as long
as they're able to hang on for a few
years let's be fair the the average rent
in this country has gone up to 950 per
month today according to the BBC when
you started in this doing by to Let's it
was half that my rents were 500 yeah and
the same properties are now giving me a
ground yes so so although interest rates
are high
so are rentals it's just the the gap
between the rental and the mortgage
payment at this particular moment in
time is is much lower than it has been
in the past but there's no question that
at some stage in the future that that
Gap will widen again and people will
start to to make money again out of buy
to let some people are still making
money some of those who are lucky enough
to already be in a fixed rate that they
took out last year like me that's more
risk thanks to you I've got my rights to
fix some of my rates if it's still 2027.
yes a lot of my properties yes so I'm
loving my 3.2 interest thank you very
much okay
the other thing is in the last few days
interest rates have started to to go
down again what actually happened was
they increased quite a bit early in this
year and then right up into the spring
they started to go down again even
though the the bank of England was
putting the rates up all the time
but in the last few days we've had quite
a few emails from lenders saying we're
putting our fixed rates down you know so
I think people who have got long-term
plans that you're recommending for buy
to lets I think they need to consider
that this is an emergency and although
it feels as if it's going to last
um a long time is that is actually only
a small moment in time uh and the
general consensus is that within the
next couple of years interest rates will
fall again do you know what really did
it for me and you told me this so I have
to credit you is the the flip between
the two-year and the five years that
gives the gain away and it does it does
because people were saying to me I was
saying what you're saying in terms of
this is this is a short-term crisis we
don't know what the future holds for
sure but into a social problem will drop
a bit
um that was my kind of gut feeling the
people people were saying but if you
look historically interest rates have
been at an all-time low
in 2019 which is very true as well yes
but talk about the reversal from the
two-year to the five effects and the
importance of that when trying to
predict the next few years of interest
rates yes yes well um uh until this time
last year if you had um a short-term
fixed rate say two years which was
normally the minimum the rate of
interest was lower than it would be if
you had a longer term three years or
five years and so the longer you had the
interest rate fixed for the higher the
interest rate and it's been like that
for quite a long time and then suddenly
in the last 12 months there's been a
reversal
so now the longer you fix the rate
generally not always but generally the
longer you fix the rate the lower the
interest rate
so the the most expensive interest rates
are the shorter ones the two-year fixed
rates at the moment
um and that's obvious what's behind that
the vendors all think that within a
couple of years interest rates will be
lower yeah and they know that everyone's
scared yes they know that everybody
wants to fix their rights as long as
possible in the classes they're doing it
now while into us there's a high yeah so
that yeah they they predict the bag to
predict the insurance will drop over the
next few months or years that's right
but there are by the way some rates that
look cheap
so they look as if they're 3.95 or four
point something uh for buy tele
mortgages
but when you look closely at the
mathematics of it
you know that if you have say a fixed
rate for two years then the lender
normally charges you a product for
coming a thousand quid or something
right yeah but these much cheaper rates
sometimes the product fee is twice that
it's four thousand dollars so when you
when you actually do the maths uh over
over the two years or whatever you're
having you're better off paying a more
contemporary rate Five Point something
or maybe early sixes at the moment
um I'm paying a normal modest uh product
fee yeah rather than uh you know living
in a in in a situation where you're
you're so desperate to make a lower
payment every month that you're you're
prepared to add quite a lot onto your
mortgage in terms of a substantial
product fee I tell the people who are in
little bit screwed the people that have
bought the wrong properties with rent
that are only just Plumbing requirements
that's a good point there because
um we've had complaints from from uh
mortgage borrowers for quite a few years
now hang on a minute my rate of interest
is only two percent but when they stress
test the transaction in other words when
they see if the rent is enough to cover
the interest rate they use say five and
a half percent which has been the
typical measure but rates are less than
half that at the moment
for this just goes to prove that the
lenders were right in setting that sort
of level they knew order that they they
knew that rates would go up at some
stage within where however long it was
20 or 25 years and so they had to be
more cautious in their approach
now that is also a good measure for
somebody going to buy somewhere
because if you go to buy somewhere
and the rent against the interest
payment doesn't Stack Up
should you be buying it nah uh because
it's not just a question can you get a
mortgage on it is it a viable buy to let
proposition uh so so it's a useful thing
to have that stress test
um uh uh it's a good thing it helps us
yes you shouldn't be buying a problem
it's going to make you 150 a month no
because then if interest rate's got by
one percent you skip it yes unless you
are convinced that as it's supposing
you've got a day job still and and so
you don't need any income from the buy
to let yeah if you're building up your
portfolio to the point where you're in a
position to give up the day job and
you're happy for the time being
um just to to tread water on it
um because you feel perhaps that the
properties in an area where the prices
are going to go up so you'll get a good
good increase in value yeah um but if
it's too close you're not going to break
even anyway because you're going to have
costs if you use a letting agent you've
got their costs Billings Insurance
um cost of having annual checkups for
the gas electricity so yeah if it
doesn't fit the stress test of most
lenders you shouldn't be buying it
anyway
um I mean the the key is to you find the
right broker and the right lender that
this way you can get the best rate
possible yeah but also find a way of
getting the maximum rep possible at the
same time which brings me on to service
accommodation yeah did you know I've
been doing service accommodations and
advocating it for many years and it's an
interesting one from a mortgage ability
perspective because if you're buying a
property and you want to rent it out
effectively as a mini Hotel yes talking
about the types of lenders and lending
for that and and how that works yes um a
few years back um if you've said Airbnb
or holiday Let's A lender
just sucked their teeth and said please
go away because it was new and and it
was it hadn't been tested and and it was
a scary thing for them like everything
else gradually gradually lenders have
come into it and they can see that it
works I even listen to Classic FM coming
here today and their advertising Airbnb
on Classic FM
um so it's it's an accepted
um established way of doing things now
so the mortgage lenders are gradually
coming into it and they've got two
approaches one is a holiday let and one
is an Airbnb the holiday lets tend to be
what they say it might be a Seaside
property or somewhere which is going to
be led to Holiday makers or the other
one is the one that might be in a town
or city next to a hospital or somewhere
else or some Works going on and so that
will be a proper Airbnb but mortgage
lenders gradually more and more are
coming into the market for Airbnb so
we're getting a wider scope however one
thing that hasn't changed for Airbnb is
that I think almost all of them if not
all of the lenders say you can't be new
to buy toilets as a borrower for Airbnb
yes so we have a lot of people come on
who who are perhaps own their own
residential property or don't perhaps
they're just tenants and they want to
start off with an Airbnb
what we recommend is they find a friend
or relative have this happen there was a
guy on my course that came to you
recently yeah yes well what he said was
um I think he was in the position where
he was a tenant yeah nothing so so I
said can you think of a friend or
relative who has got a buy to let
who's had it for at least a year maybe
two years who is prepared to be like a
silent partner and join you on this
Enterprise and he said yes I can yeah
absolutely and so then there's quite a
few lenders who say as long as one of
the applicants has got experience
um and then we'll do the Airbnb uh and
the idea is perhaps if he has a two-year
fixed maybe three years or something
like that his his friend or relative is
on there as a silent partner for that
period and then at the end of that
period we can remove them when we
remortgage the property
um so that he's back on his own again
because he then has the uh experience
that the lender wants or lots of lenders
want you know what are you generally
saying two-year fix or five year fix
it's very bespoke because we say to them
right what are you going to do with this
property are you like to sell it in the
next two years and a lot of people say
not as far as I know no I'm going to
have it for at least two years
are you going to sell it within five
years they say look there's a good
possibility I even want to sell it
within five years well I might want if
it's increased in value I might want to
raise some more money on it then to put
more money into the into the portfolio
and we say in that case perhaps have a
two-year although the rate of interest
will probably be higher than the five
here
um have a two year so after two years
you can you can review everything
um and you'll be out of penalties after
two years with that lender so you've got
a uh the freedom to do what you like
with it now the talking of five years we
talked about the stress test earlier
sometimes quite a lot of lenders will
say actually we can't lend you enough
money that you want to to buy this or
remortgages because the rent isn't quite
enough but if you have a five-year fixed
right we will we will then soften our
approach and we will give you the money
you want and the reason why they do that
is because they think well if this
person is going to be safe for five
years we and they know exactly what
they're paying then it's this is why we
can we can tweak it up a little bit for
them and so there's quite a lot of that
going on but some people who say to me
well I'm not going to borrow any more
money
I I'm not going to sell this properly
it's uh I have no plans to do anything
like that they have a five-year fixed
because the rate is lower than the
two-year yeah and sometimes the product
fee is the same so if it's a two
thousand pound product fee if you're
spreading it over five years instead of
two years it's better value for money
yeah so what are you saying about
product transfers at the moment I mean I
know a lot of people are doing that and
yes yes it's quite a good scheme we we
took out earlier this year and we
started which has worked very well for
some people so what we do is first of
all I mean we did one yesterday for a
man who only owes fifty five thousand on
his mortgage so the prospect of of
justifying moving that 55 000 mortgage
to another lender to get a slightly
cheaper rate it's not it's not going to
be mathematically viable we did have a
look but we found that the existing
lender offers is a rate that's slightly
less attractive than he could get by
remortgaging but the remarkaging comes
with costs yeah and effort whereas
staying with its existing lender it's
normally fairly straightforward so in
his case what we've done is I think his
deal is due in November so we said to
him okay here are the rates available
from your lender today and I think he's
chosen a two-year fixed rate
we've reserved that fixed rate for him
for November so he'll continue on the
existing one he get he's got which is
two point something until November then
this higher rate will take over from
November but in between time once a
month we will contact his lender and if
the rates fall we'll go back to the
lender and say we don't want that one
we've agreed we want this new cheaper
one please
and we've been on that very successfully
with a lot of clients so far this year
wow it's like having your cake and
eating it took
yes because the lenses seem to be okay
with this we always check first that the
lender is one of those who is prepared
to do that yes um but most of them are
and again some of them make a charge
small charge 100 150 quid for changing
it but most of them don't most of them
just say okay change it
um so we monitor that monthly right up
to November for this man and if the
rates fall
um that then we'll go back and say hey
there's a slightly cheaper rate let's
make a change I mean the way I see
things is if you can get a good deal now
it's a good time to buy as long as it's
cash flowing and you have to get the
right rate and you can get the right
mortgage yes as you mentioned yes
interest rates have gone up but so rents
yes yeah and if you can do a service
accommodation like Airbnb and make a a
good cash flow especially yes and sit on
the property now there are Bargains a
lot of landlords are selling they have
seen that I have seen that some of our
clients of course are in that category
what they what we're recommending they
do before they sell is look at their
portfolio yes
um and I say to them can you identify a
weak spot in there is one of those
properties that is niggling because it's
brilliant it's not doing very well it's
not working out particularly well as a
buy to let and if they say yes there's
usually one isn't there if they've got a
big enough portfolio we say well why
didn't you sell that one
um and some of them are now who've had
their properties in their personal name
for some time when they buy future ones
they buy now in a limited company so so
this is a way of them gradually working
through their portfolio and transferring
ownership from private name into limited
company yeah selling out a weaker one
and then when they buy something else
um but it's limited company it's
brilliant and I did the same thing I
ended up selling seven uh and again it
might be the EPC
um yeah so if you know that it's not
about yes past the new although they
pushed that back from 2025 to 2028 yeah
if you ever really yes yes for some
people but um yeah I like that if you if
you want to sell or you want to release
a bit of cash yes you would go through
the portfolio headache once yes um me
and my wife we're getting to the point
where when the management company would
ringers and say oh the terms complained
about the tap if like right sell that
one
let me talk to you about that point
because there's another issue that I
wanted to bring up
um quite often we speak to a client we
haven't spoken to for a year or two and
we look into the portfolio and we check
the rentals and we look down the list
and we say you're getting you're getting
450 a month for that three-bedroom house
yeah um what'd you get yeah still the
same 10 still 450 a month
um we say have you had advice from a
letting agent and if they get the advice
that 450 should really be seven
something like that yeah yeah they say
yes but that tenant's been there a long
time yes they're a very good tenant yes
um they keep the place better than I
would yeah they'd they look after the
garden and if there's a little nickel
with the property like a dripping tap or
something they don't disturb me they do
it themselves yeah because they know
they're getting it under price
nevertheless there's a big gap between
the 450 we've discussed and the 750. so
a lot of them are having to go back to
those 10 and say look sorry we have got
to put it up a little bit because
otherwise that can interfere with this
stress test we talk about right yeah it
almost devours it property as well it
does yeah if the property is only
getting 450 rounds if you ever want to
sell that property and they see that
it's only been for 450 it doesn't look
great no no I mean what we what we we me
and my wife Amanda we have the same
mentality if we've got a good talent
we've got properties where they've been
in there seven eight nine years and
they're brute yes so they're massive
under what they should be doing and we
we said you know what we'll just keep it
the same but I think it's a new interest
rates everyone understands if it's there
about 4 15 they should be by 750 if you
go to them have a conversation you can
do it at 600 yes in the middle yes um
they know they're still getting
underpriced yeah uh 950 is the average
today in in as we said
um in the in this country talking about
skips and mortgages because I know that
they were the first ever buy to let and
they've got the uh 100 mortgage thing if
you had a lot of interest yes of course
yes
um out of 100 people who apply to them
for a mortgage for that purpose yeah
only a small percentage
I tell you what it is if they're tenants
and have been tenants for 12 months at
least they can con if they fit the
mortgage
um you know category for for Skipton
they only now from their outgoings are
okay
um they can borrow uh and pay back a
mortgage no more than they've been
paying rent yeah so if their rent is 650
pounds a month their mortgage payment
mustn't exceed 650 pounds a month
so that's where it falls down a lot of
the time because the property value is
too high or and their age perhaps they
might be in their 40s or 50s yeah um
it's not it's not necessarily as good as
it sounds but it can be for the right
person it definitely can be for the
right person yeah what we have had
recently is we've had a an influx of
landlords selling properties to their
tenants and if the tenant hasn't had any
money we have found we've been able to
do mortgages for the landlord gifting a
a small amount of the equity to the
tenant that's nice and the land that was
happy to do that because it saves the
hassle of putting a property on the
market normally speaking the agent will
say if you're selling a rented property
get rid of the tenant first get have an
unoccupied property well how long is he
going to go with the void
um property before he sold it five
percent reduction in the in the value
and then it's quite an easy life the
tenants are perfect and how much is the
the fee to the estate agent two or three
thousand probably yeah so they're saving
all that
um and so
um we're doing a lot of those and so
certain land does will help with a
gifted deposit for the landlord within
reason not thirty thousand pounds or
forty thousand sometimes but but a small
amount they will they will agree with
that if the tenant can get some money
themselves together either from their
own resources or from a a gift from a
relative 100 yeah yeah and the they're
earning just an average salary yeah and
the landlord said that they would
happily reduce it to 75 grand because
they happen to really like the tenant
yes would the tenant have to buy deposit
in or if that counter the deposit uh
depends on the lender that would be this
that's got two potential hazards
um first one we know that land that
lenders valuers are cautious yeah so
they might not value it at the hundred
thousands
yeah they know how they know what's
going on when the value comes out so
they know the numbers so they might the
worst thing they could do is value it at
the 75. yeah
um so that's the first hazard and the
second Hazard is that um
there's only a few lenders who will do
them so so a short list of lenders so
that when you have a short list of
lenders to choose from it means the
interest rate might not be the most
competitive sure and you might have to
have a particularly good credit yes to
do it as well because of the limited
lenders that's it yeah yeah what are you
saying then Andrew interest only or
repayment mortgage right now
2023. for buy to lets Our advice hasn't
changed always have um interest only for
buy to let if you're really concerned to
pay Capital back ask us if we're
arranging the mortgage to make sure we
go to a lender who allows you to overpay
the mortgage the equivalent to the
capital so so in other words if your
your payment of interest only is 500 a
month but to make it a repayment
mortgage over the period you want it it
should be perhaps 650
um make sure
we find a lender who will allow you to
overpay within a limit without paying
any penalties during the fixed rate
period and the typical industry limit is
10 of what you owe so in other words if
you owe a hundred thousand this year you
can overpay 10 grand without paying any
penalty if you did that next year you
could overpay 10 of what you will then
10 to 90 000 so nine thousand
um but we have always had very strong
feelings that if you're doing buy to let
mortgages you should have interest only
for several reasons and that's proved to
be correct now because
um it can unbalance your portfolio
um the stress test on your portfolio
having repayment mortgages but also if
your interest rate you have no choice
but your interest rate doubles because
of the what's going on now you need to
to have the security of knowing that you
only have to pay the interest you don't
have to pay the capital on do you
um so yes definitely interest only so
supposing you have a Residential
Mortgage which will normally be
um capital and interest repayment it
won't normally be interest only the the
lender might well if you ring them up
and and say can you help me they might
say yes we can consider giving you
interest only for six months now if
you've just finished your present
mortgage deal which might have been only
one point something percent and now
they're offering you five point
something percent
um they might say well would you like to
fix the rate at 5.5 and have interest
only for six months
that's good that that's that helps you
because you only have to pay interest
only at five point five percent for six
months
but we say yeah that's good but come
back to us and talk to us about it
before you actually take any action
because
what's going to happen in six months
because your salary going to increase so
much so you can generate holiday to the
mortgage lender yeah I can afford a
repayment while John five and a half
percent now you might not be able to do
that so talk to us and what we've done
recently with several cases is we've
been able to rearrange the mortgage
through another lender either on our
interest only
so that it's not interest only for six
months it's interest only for the whole
mortgage period with a facility to
overpay the capital as and when they're
able to do it if especially if interest
rates go down or a part in part some
lenders will do a percentage of the
mortgage interest only and the balance
on repayment
um that's very interesting people don't
see the bigger picture sometimes it six
months oh fine I've got six months but
then you screwed up to six months after
you could be I mean it's all bespoke
it's all according to who they are and
what their position is but
um uh it's important to get independent
advice the the mortgage annuals be as
helpful as they can they are very
helpful generally but they have limits
on how far they can go with their advice
um
uh best to speak to somebody what about
people that are saying
on landlords that are considering just
paying off their MLB just because
they're worried about the rates
um it's all very well if they've got we
have had several who've said that
they've got enough money to be able to
do that and pay the mortgages off but of
course they might pay early repayment
charges
so they might be better advised we've
got several who are waiting to the end
of the early payment period then they're
paying the mortgage off but then they
have to consider that if there's a
change of plan and they want to
refinance the property at what rate will
they refinance it and then the the
refinancing costs so again it's in it's
a question of talking to them about
their whole prospects for the future and
what they want to do and yeah
um but some of them are are repaying
some of the mortgage so if they are a
hundred thousand they're paying 25 000
off which reduces it to 75 000.
even at a higher interest rate it's
still affordable and still works well
there's still a big enough gap between
the the interest payment on the mortgage
and the rental income yeah yeah it's
interesting as well because if you look
through history the best deals have
always been a lot of what's happened in
times like this yes it when there's a
crisis yes that is the time to get
excited yes and right now everyone's
freaking out yes which means brilliant
let's do it but let's do properly let's
get the right mortgage advisor let's get
the right Trend it's got the right
education let's crunch out numbers and
let's methodically crack along yes so
I'm very excited and I'm very interested
to see what does happen with rates it's
interesting the fact that they fit the
two year to five year yes very
interesting to see that you're saying
you think that there's a good chance
that he just says will actually drop and
they have out there in the next couple
of days they have yes yes I can think of
three lenders who've done this and
they're all lenders who are vitalize
only you see
it's an interesting thing as well
because people are worried oh bye so
let's go but the lenders need the
business they do because because you
think if they're a buy to let lender
only yeah and they're not doing any new
business yeah uh they're suffering like
everybody else yes they need a business
yes yes we've got to make our money yes
feed our kids
that's great well it's been really good
catching up and um thanks for coming on
the show no problem
[Music]
thank you